good morning believe nation today's
message is don't fool yourself over you
Deborah Medan don't fool yourself be
absolutely honest and clear over your
idea is it a good idea is it a bad idea
why am i doing it what is my motivation
this is apps this is essential in every
walk in life but it's absolutely crucial
for entrepreneurs I can remember times
in my business life where I've actually
done things because I wanted to do them
I had to convince myself that it was a
brilliant idea simply because I wanted
to do it and there's a world of
difference between actually taking a
cool critical look or what it is you're
about to do and then getting passionate
I hear a lot set about passion passion
is absolutely brilliant but being
passionate too early can be a very very
dangerous thing I think far more
dangerous than being passionate too
early is not being passionate at all and
I see it over and over and over again
and when I think about don't fool
yourself this is what comes immediately
to mind for me because they say the
devil always comes carrying a bag of
cash and you make the wrong decision
because you see a pile of money on the
table that you think is yours and so you
go for it only to find out that you're
never gonna get that money and I see it
all the time where people say join my
network marketing company you know you
can make tons of cash it's easy money no
problem you know within three months
you'll be up and running and the money
will just keep pouring in there's
nothing wrong with that with marketing
it just isn't the best fit for everybody
and then what happens where you see this
opportunity right join me on my path so
these vending machines or whatever it is
you see a pile of money on the table and
you fool yourself into thinking that you
actually care about this business that
you actually care about these financial
products you're gonna be selling or that
hand cream that you're gonna be selling
or the vending machine that you're gonna
be selling right that you actually care
about it because there's a financial
opportunity you fool yourself to
thinking that that's what you're meant
to do right say well you know this is
great I could I could be my own boss and
I can drive around the city and I get to
use products that are great on my hands
you know this is this is everything I
always wanted where it's really not you
really don't care at all about pan cream
and you never do and you never will and
it's the wrong business for you go do
something else and I think that's where
people fool themselves they listen to
the opinions of other people or they
read an article and they see that this
is the hot trend to get on and so they
go all in on that and yes lots of people
will make money there lots of people
will make money in network marketing
lots of people will make money in apps
lots of people make will make money in
virtual reality or whatever it is at the
same time people will make money in
traditional old growing industries too
you can make money anywhere you can make
money in any industry the most important
factor is that you actually care about
this business you care about the
customers you care about the product
you're creating you're a user you're
your own customer there's an obvious
need here you're passionate about what
you're selling because if you're not
you're just wasting your time and a lot
of people waste their money you have to
buy into this thing you have to buy
inventory first and just get stuck with
a garage for the product that never
sells and that you have no interest in
using either and so I don't want you to
fall into that trap don't fool yourself
make sure that whatever it is you're
jumping into you actually have a deep
connection to there's an opportunity yes
amazing and you have the commitment and
the passion and desire to see this thing
really work out that's my take so the
question of the day today is what do you
think most entrepreneurs are a lot of
entrepreneurs fool themselves on what
critical thinking do a lot of
entrepreneurs fool themselves leave it
in the comments below I'm gonna join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to Cloris Kylie from
cloris Kylie comm cloris thank you so
much for coming on my show as a guest
looking forward to going on your show
and also for buying a copy of my book it
really really really means a lot to me
so thank you again for watching guys I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourselves and whatever your
one word is much love I'll see you soon
let's pray so keep me